Hi Guys. Hi. Nice to be here on the stage.
Happy to share whatever
you want to ask me.
And I actually spent a bit of time up
in the creative labs one day and uh,
just saw some amazing things.
So if there's anyone in here
that I might've met hello again,
because I saw lots of kinds of music
called music apps. They're making it.
So folks here in the audience
might know you from, uh,
songs that were licensed to voc
or Zach Braff garden state or a,
your collaborations with Taylor
swift or Ariana Grande Day.
Or they might know about your
performative technology, uh,
endeavor in the Mimeo gloves. They
might've heard about creative passport.
They might also have heard about
you doing the Harry Potter, um,
curse in child soundtrack. Uh, all of
these things are out there in the world,
but seems breathtaking in their,
their scope.
How do you think about yourself when you
introduce yourself at the allegorical
party? W how do you consider
yourself? What's your identity?
I don't know. I just say I'm, I'm,
I like enjoy anything that kind of is
around the intersection of music and tech.
That's what I said. I don't go to like a
musician. I'm a producer. I'm a performer.
I'm an engineer and I want some Grimey's
I just go,
I mean I'm into music and tech.
I'm into music and tech. Okay.
That's what I said. There's the,
the big umbrellas you consider one of
the things I've heard you reference a
couple of times and it seems
almost contradictory to my,
my image of you,
um,
is only do what you can
see in the headlights.
Can you talk about what that means to you?
I would love to, um, before the days
of Google search engine, um, uh,
we had a thing called Yahoo and, uh,
one day I was in the studio and I think
it's a nice story. Um,
and so I was there, um,
kind of going round and round in circles
trying to finish this song. Um, I, I'm,
so I am in my studio,
this is the first time I recorded a
studio and recorded an album on my own.
So I was in the studio constantly,
all by myself for like a year.
And so it does send you a bit mad.
And because I didn't have an a and r man
or anyone that would come in and go, oh,
that's really good. Oh, you should turn
some more up, or whatever they say. Um,
I, uh, I was going, man, a man and
so I couldn't finish this song.
So I went onto the search engine and
I just said, how do you write songs?
Um,
and I found this article about this writer
novelist who had written this little
blog and it said in it and do what
you can see and the headlights.
And what she meant was if in the song
you can see that there's a high hat that
needs fixing or that you could,
or you're trying to finish
the lyric and you know,
you can see the color of his eyes,
then just do that.
Just write that bit and
just keep chipping away.
And eventually you will see the full
path ahead of you and you'll see the,
you know, all this, all the
landscape. But it's that kind of, Oh,
I've got so much to do, but so much to
do. Um, and it's overwhelming and it's,
you can't breathe. Um, and then
you just remember, we'll do it.
You can see now just do that.
Don't see,
don't do all this complicated
stuff that's far away. You know,
you have to get to it eventually, but you
can't see it just yet. So just do that.
So that's what I mean. Yeah. And I use
that a lot, um, in everything from like,
how do I look after my child this morning
when I've got to get to this interview
and I've got, you know, I just said
do he just seen the headlights,
which is make sure she has breakfast
in it. Um, and that's just, yeah,
it seems to me
how are supposed to feed them.
I hear I do six months.
I didn't see it every meal.
You know how to skip even one.
Yeah,
that's true.
It's very strict rules.
Um,
so one of the many things that you've
juggled a is the Harry Potter curse child
a soundtrack. We're going
to see a quick video, um,
introducing that album,
which has just been released.
[inaudible]
that is a bit of the play,
which is on Broadway here,
which is wonderful. Um, and
yeah, for about four years ago,
I got a call from a friend called Steven
Huggett who isn't movement director.
Tony has, he used to have this
group called the frantic assembly.
And when I released a,
well just after I released a song,
an album called speak for yourself,
which is the same album,
but I couldn't finish that song.
And I really sat by myself with my own
label and eventually licensed it to Sony
because I couldn't deal with all the
main orders. Um, and so, but before that,
um, I got this call from this Guy Steven
Holl get back then like 20 years or 15
years ago. And he's like,
are these annoying me by the
way? Should I take them off?
Are they present because
they're really annoying? Um,
anyway, so yeah, he was like, I love
this album. Speak for yourself. Could I,
I want to put it in this
play that I'm working on.
And there's going to be like people
dancing around it. And I was like, okay,
that sounds really good. And I didn't
ask him for payment and I was just like,
that sounds good. Yeah,
okay, here you go. And I,
I like tweaks and things that made it a
bit longer and, and that kind of stuff.
And then it went into this play and
it was really great. And I loved,
it was the first time I'd seen dance
to my music and I really enjoyed it.
Um,
but they didn't ask for payment,
but if I had been signed to a major label
at the time, they would have been like,
Oh yes,
I can just spend the whole year discussing
how much she should get for this and
then you won't be able
to use it anyway. Um, so,
um, so, so I basically, yeah, it was
really, it was really great. And then we,
we made friends and we kept
in touch. And then, you know,
he did all these amazing things and
then the net in, and not the next call,
but I call,
uh,
four years ago was him saying
hi images or any as he calls me,
I'm working on this play and can't
really tell you what it's about,
but they love your music
and like all this stuff.
Cause I did all this weird orchestral
stuff and I'm like, uh, Acapella,
a strange stuff for an, a compliment
for an old silent movie. And,
and nobody ever gets to hear that stuff,
but he loves me and he loves all of my
new music and he knows it all really well.
And so he was putting all
these random bits in there,
which hardly anyone's heard, and
it felt really good. And he's like,
I think they really just want you to meet
the music. Um, and I was like, who, who,
who is it? Um, and he said, I can't tell
you, but it's about a boy with a scar.
And I was like, okay, it's
a bit of a giveaway. Um,
and so I looked up online,
I saw his name connected to this creative
team who'd already announced they're
doing the play, and then I was like,
that's exciting. Um, so then, yeah,
I met up with Sonya who he's,
she's the producer and they
offered me the job and uh, yeah,
life took a very different turn. Um, yeah.
What was your relationship to the Harry
Potter Universe before that? Yeah,
um, thin, um, quite distant. Um,
I really don't like reading very
much. Um, I mean, that's not true.
I like the information that's in the book.
I just don't like the process
of actually reading it. Um, so,
and I've never enjoyed, I've never
enjoyed that my dad thinks that if he,
if it wasn't down to him kind
of showing me going through,
he thinks like dyslexic and maybe
because I really struggle, like,
you know, getting the words in my head.
Um, maybe that's why I like making my own.
Um, so anyway, um, so yeah,
so that's,
that's how I ended up in there and
fascinating. And if I can ask
for those of us who were much,
much deeper into the universe,
um,
can we fan boy and fan girl
out for a second and ask,
did you hang out with JK Rowling?
Did she invite you to her house,
which I assume is a magical castle that
you can only access by a unicorn or
magical boat or something?
Yeah,
yeah. Um, I have, I did meet the lady
herself few times. Yeah, she was on,
she was on set, quiet. Um, and yeah,
she's very nice to me.
She says she actually,
I think when I first met her she did
this division and I was like, um,
no, she's, she's very happy because she,
I mean I discovered that they really
wanted, um, they really wanted somebody,
British, a composer that's British
and it was a woman. Um, so,
so I was in there really
at all. Um, I would,
I think also with the health of Steven
and the fact that the director and him
are like best buddies,
it all, it all helps.
So can you tell us about the
creative process that cause as,
as I've heard you describe it,
sort of it's a creative process within
a creative process because they're,
they're working on, they're their own
thing. It's really awful, isn't it?
It's that thing, Ben. No names. Dot. Raja.
You can, you can absolutely call
me garages. It's completely fine.
Well now, even now we even, you have
your on and I quote you, I'm like, um,
so then, then often, um,
your question was what would
your, your presence, sorry. Yes.
So the creative process was, um, they
really liked a lot of existing material,
um, but they needed it
adapted. Um, but they had it,
it's a five hour play and they wanted a
lot of it to be music underscored. Um,
but they also, like, there's kind
of three different types of music.
There's music that they interact with,
which is when they're on the stage and
they're like meeting [inaudible] music,
there's the underscore and then
they've seen changes. Like, you know,
a wall goes across and it's like,
hmm, oh, I think it's like that. Yeah.
Um, and so the underscore bit is like
quite a lot of existing material that just
kind of fumbling away in the background
that's been adapted and stretched and
added different things and lots of high
frequencies taken out because it kind of
gets in the way of the talking.
Um,
so I learned a lot about how to kind of
sculpt around the vocal, like, you know,
human voice area. Um, and then a lot of,
um, yeah, lots of drones. Um, lots
of vocal loads of vocalizations.
There's no lyrics actually is any one
bit it hasn't there Rick. Um, and did,
that's from Hiden seat. Of
course. I didn't have to
put my famous song in there.
Um,
so that's the one,
the one song I really wanted
with the lyric and I didn't want,
it didn't feel right to have me sing in
it and they didn't want to have me sing
in it anyway.
So I got my friend's choir to sing it
and then I kind of added the vocal layers
underneath and made no strains and, and
uh, but most of the time it was just,
it was all about the transitions.
And that was really,
really fun and really tested
my theory skills and to like,
how do I get from that kid, how do I
modulate in there to them and how do I,
you know, do this. Um, so there's a
lot of existing material and I mean,
luckily,
um,
over the years I've been quite
vigilant into kind of making,
making sure that all of the songs have
their stems and they're all documented
and kind of filed quite nicely. So all
of the songs from pick for yourself up,
um, or have like John Strings, vocals,
backing vocals, effects, blah, blah, blah,
um, weird sounds arpeggiated
things, et cetera, et cetera. Um,
and then so I was lucky enough to be able
to pull that in and those ones that I
hadn't done, I've got this awesome, um,
assistant called Alexi and he
was in my studio back in, uh,
back in the village
where we live. And, um,
and he would be kind of getting those
together and then dropping them into
Dropbox.
I'm into Ableton sessions where then
I was sitting in the theater for about
three months and just with my little,
you know,
computer and my little hard drive
and whatever and had my, uh,
my microphone and sing little toys and
then I was just there the whole time.
And my only regret is that I didn't
really get to talk it to anyone other than
did you like that or could you make that
a bit more like this or could you make
it a bit less? Um, and uh, yeah,
so I didn't really get to talk
to the gang very much. Um,
and I was literally there from 10 in
the morning until 11 at night and it was
always, well not always, but I was quite
a lot of time. The last one, the last,
the last one in there saying
hi to the security guard. Um,
and you took all of this music,
it's something like a hundred cues and uh,
created an album. Yeah. That
sort of a cohesive album.
What was that process like for you?
Yeah. So the, the, in a theater,
it was really great cause there's like
tons of inputs to kind of, you know,
react against and be like, oh that sound
works beautifully with the light. Oh,
that sound as peacefully with the sound
effects or ah, the piece of that person.
So all of these are kind of affirmations
that that's working, that's working,
keep going, which you don't get in the
studio when you're all by yourself. Um,
and so,
but at the same time,
because it's a big theater system and
you don't hear a lot of the detail in the
mix, so it's kind of getting away with
murder in terms of what I could mix in the
time that I had,
which is two and a half hours of music
that like quite a lot of it done also
from scratch. Um, and so when I
finally took that back into my studio,
you know, it was like, oh my
goodness, I've got so much work to do.
It's like a gazillion pops and clicks and
all kinds of things I had to draw out.
Um, and then, uh,
and then just making it sound lush and
beautiful and layered and giving it the
attention that I do to my own records,
but to like when it's a 78 minute album,
it's like as much as I could fit
on a CD, physically possible. Um,
and it's 42 tracks and it's so it goes
into four acts and then like one long
piece of music for 20 minutes, another
long piece of music for 20 minutes,
but it's the going through 14 or 15 keys.
So that's where the kind of,
how do you get from this key to
that key in three, four from seven,
eight to today? Um, there's really fun.
There's a lot of hard work and I
did most of it standing up, um,
because I also had a life at
that time in a flat in London.
And so there's a little
bit just standing up,
but it was quite good from a pollster.
Yeah.
Excellent. Uh, a personal recommendation,
I've been listening to
the album for a while now.
A walking through the city and listening
to that on headphones gives you a very
weird,
a magical layer of New York that very
surprising because he did a wonderful job
sort of making that,
that feel magical. Yeah.
Which sounds like it was
kind of withdrawal and t um,
kind of the other, um, kind of
secret weapon I had was, uh,
I developed with a company
called sonic chill,
my own set of virtual instruments of
all my favorite sounds in my studio,
so that I could basically
take them on the road with me.
So I could have my Embera, I could
have my cello, like harmonic stuff.
I could have my cocktail kit, I could
have my Worley's your, your marks,
a phone I read, which is a ball
sort of socialists trumpet. I think
it's a bit like an auto Hartford,
but it has 20 things on it. Um,
and then I what you were thinking
of. Um, so yeah, it looks fine.
I see Mike and it's slow a bit
slow today. Anyway, so, um,
caught that, that out. Um, yeah, so I
have this, we call it the box of tricks.
Um, which is quite funny because it ends
up being a box of checks in a magical
theater piece. And I used all
of those sounds, um, you know,
to basically make things sound like me.
Yeah.
So I would always use the Mark's
phone and I'd use the choir of me.
I could play quite as on my,
I had sampled my voice.
So if anyone wants to make sounds
that song, it sounds a bit like me.
Just find the box checks and
just go like Mark's phone,
bit string of focal vocal
harmony things and some men.
Speaking of instruments, um, I wanted
to turn to the mimeo gloves. Um,
we've got a quick little
video to introduce you all
to this if you haven't seen
him for.
And here she goes,
Huh,
oh,
what do you get me out of bed?
Okay. So it's really not a very good
example because what happened before?
It's not your fault,
it's not your fault.
I think it was my team reason gave
you that. But basically, yeah,
well I'd done, previous to that
is I had a lift my voice by going,
catching my voice and then it would create
a leap and then I would catch another
leap.
Well,
I'd actually put that aside and then I
would catch another loop and then we'll
put that aside and then I
catch that, et Cetera, cetera.
And what I'm doing is I'm going,
uh, posture fessed up, um,
his record. And, um, when I'm out
of that zone, it goes to play.
Um, or when it goes to this so that it
plays, and then it continues to play.
And then I can't remember exactly,
cause that was ages ago, but, um,
it's something like when they want to
pull up the volume of the first leap,
then I would use my finger like this
and they would just be like up and down,
up or discuss, beat up. And
it'd be 120 127 in Mitie. Nope.
But like 100% a loudness. Um, and
then if I wanted to add reverb,
I just use my secret finger, a posture
which, um, basically activates, uh,
the reverb,
um,
feeder or like the Po in my software.
And it just says from naught to 100%.
So if I was like,
just sound like now, but if I was like
over there, it would be like, dude,
it doesn't a massive
cave. Um, and then, yeah,
so I play like baselines or he might
play tinkling sounds or it's just things
that I do anyway in a,
when I perform previously,
um,
you know,
you kind of have to be kind of a little
bit barricaded by give you want to
sample staff or you know,
you're locked in to the physical nature
of whatever books you're using and the
gloves are,
you know,
basically controllers at your
fingertips and you can just, uh, yeah,
just be very expressive to something which
is quite boring actually in real life.
It's just like turn off a thing
to 100%. It was like eat. Um,
but you could do that really expressive,
like, yeah, because I feel like that,
but this is much more like, oh, she's
making her voice bigger, you know,
or she's catching her voice and now
she's meeting it left or right. You know,
or maybe even in surround,
which I'm doing on the tour,
kind of moving it around a three d
space. Um, and uh, and then, yeah,
just kind of sampling my voice,
bringing in vocoders harmonizers
I can harmonize with my voice. Um,
sometimes I integrated with
like an IRA, a camera, well,
they don't make them
anymore, but a connect, um,
and they would map the stage into
different zones. So I could be like,
when I'm over there, then, um,
you know, make the drums more,
uh, kind of sparse and when I'm back here
and make them more phonetic or when I'm
over there, switch Mohammed Hazard
to minor or when I'm over here,
or when I'm in the middle, take out my
harmonizer. So using the spatial, uh,
this, the stage spatially to
effect the kind of bigger, um,
parameters in change in a system
like Ableton pro tools or whatever.
Um, so it's basically like
a mapping device, but how
it feels is you take on, um,
the physicality of something which
doesn't have a physical representation.
It's like a filter or a bunch of effects.
Uh,
it doesn't have a thing that,
it's not like a basic tasks like that.
That's the Bass Guitar.
Um, it's like a rebirth a,
so you become the reverb and you become,
you know,
the mixing desk and you become
the multiple voices or um,
yeah, the, the thing that only downside
though I discovered from it, um,
other than like lots of programming and
to kind of get it so it feels real to
human. So the you'll never,
you'll never even thinking about,
actually I'm going to bring in my reverb
now I'm going to something in my voice.
So just, it's just, it becomes second
nature. I'm going to call my voice,
going to make it bigger. Now I'm going
to add some heart and some delays.
You kind of create a gestural language.
The more and more you use the system
because it obviously has a bit of software
in between it called Glover. Um, what'd,
you could also add other inputs so you
don't have to use the gloves with Glover.
Uh, you can use, you can use connect,
you can use a myo, you can use an iPhone,
you can use your leap motion,
you can use whether you know,
the types of inputs and then use them to,
you know,
move around things in Ableton or whatever.
So the gloves are essentially just trying
to get away from this limited limited
space.
I,
I felt of trying to add lots more
gear to create a fluidity or a kind of
spontaneity on the stage.
Sure. And, and for you, now that
you've actually developed these, uh,
do you find when you perform that
you're in them most of the time?
All the time? Yeah. Yeah.
I wear them all the time. All the time,
the stage because why take them off?
They're quite pretty and they
don't eat anything. Um, the,
they basically have like
eight Ben sensors. They've
got one to two, two and one.
They have lights for feedback and you
can program the lights to do whatever you
want. It might be like turn it red
when I'm in record, which, you know,
it's been a quarter, but it's nice for the
audience to see it. Oh, it's in record,
it's gone red.
Um,
and then it's a battery has got an imu
so you can get your kind of positional
data and just got exit accelerometer
so you can be like John Peaks.
Um, and I do ag guitars
and it was really fun. Um,
and uh, yeah, so that kind of
combination. Then you've got your axes,
so you've got your pitch,
you've got your,
and you've got rolled and then you've got
different zones backwards, forwards, up,
down.
And the combination of that leads to so
many possibilities because if you have a
keyboard and you're like,
I'm going to play a squeegee bass sound.
So he might be like doing and you want
it to go away now or something. Um,
you could do that for
pressure with pressure.
It can make it slightly harder
if you want it here now.
But if you want it to like do that and
change the tone or something around it,
um,
you would have to use your other hand,
which is an entirely
consumed by going well. Um,
and you were like suddenly just playing
a three note baseline with a wow thing,
but you could just be going, we all like
that the same, but just your whole hand,
then you can move around
the stage and do, um, yeah.
So it's all good for everything and it's
not good if you want to pay like some
black men in off with
your fingers. Um, but you,
you do that on the piano because
that's what the panel is for. Um,
it's really for all of the,
the unseen bits,
the bits that don't have a voice or a
physical nice. But you do get lost in it.
That's anything cause interesting.
You just close my eyes all the time
and I'm like in the zone I'm paying,
I hadn't see kind of layering my voice.
I'm drinking in a harmonizer and
I'm like, God, I finished a song.
Did I actually look at anyone?
Um, because it's like you're,
you're playing and it's like Phil's.
Yeah. Cause I have in as well.
I like just hear that
sound and I'm just like,
you just get lost because you
don't touch anything, you know, uh,
like a machine or whatever.
It just kind of,
if becomes really like a second
skin of visceral experience. Yeah.
Fascinating. Yeah, it's really cold.
And where in the development
process are you right now? Is it,
are you,
are you licensing it to someone or you
are you looking for a funding partner or
you,
why?
Well, I was gonna wait
til later, but okay. Uh,
no, it's you, what we've been doing
because it has been quite hard, you know,
I'm not, um, kind of corporate structures
and all that stuff's not my forte.
Um,
so we,
we have a team and they've grown
over the eight years since we started
developing it for my own personal
fun time use. Um, which then became,
we did some conferences and things like
this and one before and over time we've
had loads of interest,
tons and tons of emails that we set.
We set up a company eventually cause it's
like, well, maybe we should make them,
um, instead of, you know, just for my
own personal enjoyment or for my, my,
my shows. And so we did start
to development, but that's
a huge curve, you know,
to have to make it something
that everyone can use.
Software that's intuitive hardware
that's robust and you know,
cheap enough to, you know, make
enough of them. Um, so we have,
we've made like 50 handmade pairs for
people over the years and now we are
getting much closer to releasing
something this year. Um,
which just a hundred pairs,
but they will be manufactured and it
will be a lot kind of down and not that
much down in cost, but maybe in five years
time. So if enough people buy Teslas,
there'll be like two print next
year. Um, so, you know, it's, uh,
it is that they're, the early
adopters do pay the higher price,
but they get the benefit of medicine,
service and whatever. Again. So yeah.
This year we're going to release them.
Um, we have released the mini mew.
If you have a small child in your life,
um,
you can make a your own glove. Um,
it's quite basic, but it's still fun.
Um, and you can build it and code it
yourself. Um, and it's called the mini me.
Yeah. I can't wait to see it
that way. You'll go, well, I do,
I do have a younger sister who
might be interested in such,
but I can't wait to see a ballet where
the, where the dancers become musicians.
Yeah.
Uh,
so whoever out there is
doing that shouldn't do that
because it seems built for
a hybrid art.
Yeah. It's, it's you kind of, because
you use your whole body, maybe your hand,
right. You, you know, you
don't just be like, Hey,
even though you might be just getting
like that, it kind of wanted to get like,
you know, it's like I'm catching
was then, um, so for, for
the dancers, the, you know,
they use a whole bodies and you could,
um, I mean for fine detailed sounds,
it's great, but you could equally
use an infrared camera, you know, um,
or kind of an array, uh, to, to
have a play space but some dancers,
but combined with the gloves you
could get more detailed and you know,
really amazing timing. Like you
don't notice any latency at all. Um,
yeah,
it's really fun.
Well, speaking of, uh, broad,
uh, shifts in technology,
we wanted to talk about
creative passport and we have a,
a brief snippet of a video.
You can see the longer, um,
full video on the youtube.
Um, but for the moment, uh,
we'll show you this,
the creative passport,
an identity in a searchable database for
music makers to upload and share that
information.
Everything you'd like to share about
you as a music maker verified and in one
place mat and empower the global music
maker community as you list and link to
your music and sound contributions.
Add unique descriptive data to your
profile and individual works to increase
discoverability for brand partnerships,
playlisting sinks, collaborations,
live or session bookings at the same time,
enabling music services to innovate,
benefiting both us and our audiences.
This is an identity that belongs to and
works for you while also connecting all
of your external existing
ideas in one place.
Imagine uploading your
biography only once,
but updating simultaneously
across all services. Sounds good.
Who's going to build it?
You and I, we all are.
Step by step with music makers
and services informs me,
host all over the world on our ongoing
music and tech tall, interested.
Show your support.
Sign up.
Keep up to date with the
latest developments and get
involved at my CLF in music
to or let's bring this
necessary missing layer,
a music maker database to life for the
health of our global music ecosystem
because let's face it,
nobody else can do it for us.
The creative passport by music
makers for everyone. There we go.
That's so join up there. We don't
really have anything at the moment.
This is more like a kind of call to
action for musicians to think about their
identity. You think about what that means.
Think about, uh, ownership of data, um,
about getting organized,
really about having a place in the world
where you can say that is the digital
me.
That's where I as a creative
self exist because, um,
you know, it's great to have all these
different services and they have their own
identities for you. Oh,
you make be, you know,
you have a profile on Twitter and
the alarm and all these other things,
but where are you?
I feel very torn apart,
feel very like a big massive tentacle in
the oceans. Just, I don't have a center,
like you're speaking to my center as a
physical thing, but I don't have that.
And more and more as we kind
of progressed into, you know,
developments in AI and discoverability,
incubation and, and the,
I really believe that the future of
work is going to be around our unique
selling points,
about how we,
how we express who we are in the digital
space so that our cells are working 24,
seven on our behalf, in our words,
perhaps in our, uh, in, in our,
with our ethos, um,
interfacing with the world.
And so when it comes down to music,
um, how do we present ourselves?
Uh, the, the, we have a major problem
in the music industry whereby, uh,
you know, the commercial music
industry didn't adopt, uh,
the technology of MP three. I didn't
see enough to serve as this incredible,
amazing opportunity to like go,
wow,
this is life changing for
musicians and the industry.
Let's get on this and make
it something really great.
And instead they're kind of in its,
sweep it under the carpet
and put people in jail. Um,
and really just people wanted
to share music that they loved.
And so what happened was the,
you had a huge disassociation from the
music and the people that made it then it
just never managed to catch up.
And the music industry has been trying
to catch up and of basically firefighting
every day as people tried to
innovate on this very crooked, um,
kind of heavy, clunky industry. Um,
so there's like thousands of services
and I've spoken to hundreds of them who
want to build new services on,
you know, using existing music,
but to get to reach that point where
they have the permission to do that,
to license the music,
it's just not viable.
They have to raise so much money with
VC that then only leaves little tiny
scraps for the musicians
in the end, if any. Um,
and it's a very lengthy process and
I just feel more than ever we have an
opportunity with new technologies,
um,
where we could create an open database
of works that the whole world could come
around and create this kind of Alexandria,
this library of,
of content whereby all of the music
services, the labels or publishers,
the collection societies who all have
their own databases at the moment,
costing the huge amounts of money,
um,
that they have to keep updated
and very fine, all that stuff. Um,
and they're all incomplete and they
all compete with one another. Um,
but if that was just,
just get rid of that,
we don't need to have multiple versions
of the same thing and all slightly
different than all, slightly
bad. Let's just have,
let's share into a space
and contribute to that,
um, that, you know, alive
kind of world of music and,
and data and an augment what's already
there into something that can be tuned
into by all the services so they don't
have to have that weight on their back
basically road. So speaking
of that, you say, um, um,
Mycelia you,
you see this as a potential,
a portal for income.
Can you talk about how
blockchain a relates to, uh,
creative passport or doesn't? Yeah, sure.
Um, so for me, you know, I've been in
the music industry 23 years, it's very,
very hard to know where your
money is at any one time.
We spent about a year trying to
research just the income for one song,
just one song,
and it's taken like a team of seven
students on and off for a year just to try
to get to the bottom of what,
where, where does it come from?
What does that radio station,
what does that thing over there,
why is that a match up with that?
Um,
and that's for me with a team of people
going into the offices of the Pos and
the collection societies get,
could you explain this?
I don't really understand that. And
we're still like only 5% there. Um,
so it's, it, it's an insane
amount of complication for,
uh, which, which comes from, you
know, the physical, you know,
the old day a hundred years ago,
you know,
how do we pay a publisher when
something gets paid on the radio?
And it was much simpler.
Um,
so the creative passport is really just
about us putting our flag in the sand
musicians at the moment, verifying each
other through peer to peer verification.
Like we haven't a QR code.
You just shine your camera on someone
else's Qr Code and you go, okay,
I verify who you are.
And that is a thing that then creates
a trust network around all the music
makers across the planet in time. Um,
but we're not ready for that yet. Um,
we're just doing a very kind of,
we may need just going around the world
doing this tour where I did concerts,
I do workshops, I show off my gloves,
I give comp, I do conferences,
I do accumulate, I do whatever I can. Um,
and we meet with music makers in
services and we talk about this future
ecosystem because essentially if we had
like it's incredibly rich data source,
um, linked to the actual content, um,
linking out to all of the musicians
who contributed to those works,
then you can imagine all these amazing
possibilities of discoveries and
connections and offerings of jobs and new,
you know,
somebody wants to book somebody,
a private concert because they saw the
heard something in Spotify or Google or
whatever, youtube and they
went, oh, well, um, I really,
really liked that person's work. I'm going
to, I'm going to try and book her. Um,
and maybe you do it right from the
song. Um, and you, you leave or you say,
I love that trumpet player.
I want to,
I want to put that chunk of plywood
for the trumpeter, make film. Um,
and then they like put the trumpet player.
Um,
but if we don't have a way to kind of go,
here I am and here are my songs.
We don't have anything to build from.
We don't have a home.
Imagine you were at a, like a, a
large influential tech company,
um, talking, uh,
to some very handsome and smart employees,
how would you convince them to support
you and how could they support a creative
passport?
Yeah,
it's a good question. I think we're not,
we're not ready for like big integration.
Yeah. Um, we need to,
we need to go kind of and create a
ground swell among musicians. So they,
they get,
they kind of own this space because this
is a autonomous thing we need to do. Um,
we need to convince music makers to take
charge of their data and to really like
take their digital self seriously.
So at the moment we are talking with
tons of services. Um, we're, you know,
might have four or five,
a little handful by April or May when we
come in the tour around here and we do
more so to being on more music makers.
But, you know, we're not ready for that.
Like, it's not like my space or
linkedin. It's not like it's not ready.
It's just imagine if you owned this,
imagine if you owned your
identity. Um, and what could,
what could grow from that because then
if we reach like a thousand or 10,000,
what's going to be the tipping point
for someone, you know, a company,
an organization like Google to go,
we're going to integrate, you know, oh,
youtube service with the creative
passport and that would be mega,
but we're not ready for
that yet because it's not,
you don't have an incentive enough just
yet because we need to have, you know,
we would need to have hundreds of
thousands before it's of interest.
Right. So, so you need musicians,
maybe some in the audience and,
and other,
other people out there in the youtube
audience to come and sort of be a part of
the community and how help shape that
so that you become a large enough
organization that so that you can, uh,
more, yeah. Awesome. Wait. Yeah. Okay.
Fascinating.
Because, um, yeah, we, we know we
have representatives on our behalf,
like labels and publishers
and collection societies,
but a lot of us don't
like so many musicians.
I don't have any way to get in,
even into any industry because they
might be in Sudan or they might be in,
who knows where they might be.
They have no way to get onto the ladder.
And if we can try and,
you know,
reach our handshake across the Mexican
wave across the world or whatever, um,
to these musicians,
then we're bringing them in to this truly
global community and music community
that then hopefully all the
services will start to think,
oh well that's actually really interesting
cause now made me change to this mark
and this mark and this,
you know, and that's their
incentive. Um, but for us it's,
you know, it's how can we create, uh, uh,
a beautiful healthy living
kind of ecosystem from which
these services can grow
on kind of on our, uh, that makes sense
for us. And then with truly sustainable.
And then we can have, you
know, centuries of wonderful,
beautiful music cause the
musicians are supported. Um,
I think we have a question for you.
I think my selenium is very
interesting. Um, I'm kind of curious.
Uh,
so it,
you obviously need the three majors
to be involved. You don't think so.
And I think we need them know.
How does Merlin feel about it?
Um, the thing is it's like,
it's outside of licensing.
This is about your like personal identity.
It's my skillsets. It's my projects.
It's my interests. It's my
philosophy. It's my biography.
It's that aren't actually at
this moment to do with my songs.
They would link into a songs database,
which my Celia isn't.
My scene is like the vision,
the blue sky imagination of the future.
But the creative passport is
a thing. It's like an APP, um,
trust anchor for other services to be
able to go, oh yeah, that is imaging.
He cause she's got a credit passport
and she has been verified by her peers,
blah blah blah. Um, so if you
wanted to like go and look at Gig,
some promoter could pretty
much trust you because that is,
you'd be verified by your peers and you
have a good track record and that kind
of thing. So at the moment, um,
where the record ended, the right,
the kind of the majors are going to get
interested is when this database does
start to emerge, which is starting
to emerge in places like Sweden.
There's one in Malta,
there's one,
and actually here there's
going to be a new one, um,
around the music modernization
act around them, mechanicals,
how they're going to
be paid to the writers.
And that's something that just
passed a few months ago in Congress.
So they have to build that in the
next two years. And I'm going, hello,
IBM and that Cli. Um, how are
you going to do that without, uh,
the music makers?
How you're going to build that without
us being able to add and add to the
content that you have around
your publishers because
that's how they're going to
build it.
They're going to combine the big
publishers together and create the another
database, um, but it's only going to be
as good as their combined databases. Um,
and it won't. The problem
with that is that, you know,
whether they're guilty of it or not,
um,
is that the money that comes in from the
services will then go to this body. Um,
and then the money that they can't be
distributed because they don't know the
writers because they're too small fry and
it's too much effort for them to do it.
Um, we'll just go back to the
writers that they do have. They do,
they do look after after four years or
whatever the deal is that it will be.
It's probably something like that.
Um,
it will get redistributed back to
the original writers that they,
they look after so that the other writers
are all around the world and all the
smaller writers won't get that money.
And that's tiny amounts to
two these other artists.
But to them it could be like 50
quid or 100 or thousand kids. Um,
so,
so when they create that we want the
credit passport to be able to enable
individual musicians to be able to
automate into and clean, uh, you know, uh,
a weight kind of point to this
is how to pay me or this is,
this is my collection snotty.
Well this is actually me.
There's missing that here so that we
can tidy up and do the job for them that
they can't afford to do
because it's tiny amounts. Um,
so the majors like the records side of
things because they don't have, you know,
your Isr c and SWC WC two codes
that you have your recording,
any publishing. Um, there is no shared
database at that, which is crazy.
Um,
and so if this does start to emerge,
that may be where the majors start to
pile in there recorded data and that might
start to flourish and
become this big Alexandria.
Who knows if we can kind of make,
if we can find a way in for the
musicians and it can, it can further,
otherwise it will just became, become
another kind of claiming house, um,
kind of closed space, which will have all
this money put into it by the, you know,
public money. Um, but it
won't be further reaching.
It will just be another close
database and that there'll be a shame.
So we're, we're running a little low
on time. I'm sorry to interrupt. Um,
I did kind of sort of,
I mean it's such a complicated,
which is why we need to simplify
and that's when they're going to come
on board is when you like when you say
look, all that kind of accounting stuff
that you do and all that really annoying
paperwork and that he just like, Oh
God, I wish I didn't have to do this.
When that disappears because we have smart
contracts and payments. And you know,
what I'd say to you though is that that
assymetry of information is basically a
competitive advantage for labels to be
able to bargain with people like Spotify.
And when you have 70 or 80% of
Spotify as catalog coming from majors,
it puts them in this position where
they have to ingest majors data.
Uh, and this is where I'm sort of like,
you don't, you need the majors on board.
Yeah. So that's a good example.
And the thing is, is that you have,
if you look at the longterm,
um, the majors, you know,
they might hold licenses for,
I think there's a maximum of 35 years.
Okay.
70th. I mean at the Beatles stuff
is about to come out of licensing.
It was from the 50s.
So yeah.
Yeah. So, but it's like,
if you think of all the new material
and most that the trend is, you know,
big labels hold large amounts of existing
work and younger up and coming artists
or people like myself,
I own our own works and we have
small holdings around them and works.
So how can we make that really
easy so that people like Spotify,
I can deal with that.
Definitely.
So it's a chicken and egg problem.
It is. Yeah. And we all need to be
the chicken or the egg, whichever way,
but we need to get on with it.
We need to make the first move basically.
Yeah, that's fine. We have
another question over here. Yeah,
I have a completely ever question.
I assume like writing and forming,
wearing the gloves kind of causes you to
make different creative decisions than
you would if you were just using a
regular midi controller with like standard
coders.
Are there other technologies that you
think should be utilized more or really
are like,
aren't kind of getting the attention
that they could that could have that same
potential to change the
way that people either uh,
right informed music or experience it?
Hmm. Interesting question. Um,
I mean
how,
why and perform music the way I
really enjoy the kind of the unknown.
Like, oh, there's something
over there I haven't tried yet.
Or there's an input there that I've
never had to deal with like audience,
heartbeat info or something or like,
um,
I didn't galvanic skin
response or something. Um,
like what would id musically if I knew
the audience that actually I'm trying to
develop a thing. Like it may never happen
because lots of things don't happen,
but um, it's just a simple, it's,
it's actually got a terrible name.
It's called the love glove.
I know it's going to be
mad at US shiny material.
Is this a way that I
thought it'd be nice to,
for the audience member to have
like they could show their love,
like I love this bit. Um, instead of
like taking camera pictures or like,
or like clapping at the end
so that I could see, oh,
somebody really likes that bit, you know,
or I'll do, we need, they've got a thing.
And just like that little eye contact.
And I think when you get
those kind of bits, you know,
from the audience, um, isn't,
isn't it? Does it a lighter?
Oh, just, yeah, I suppose so.
I suppose that's true. It's really only
for the slow songs. I didn't know why.
Yeah, it might be something. I
Dunno, I was thinking about like,
could then I could give back the nerve
and I could like kind of pump up the law
and then they could get more love in
their hand and then it would kind of die
down if they use too much of it all the
time, so it doesn't get too annoying.
Anyway, I just, I just, yeah, it's
true. They could just use a lighter.
You just saved me like 10,000 pounds.
I should bring it into my team.
Take a, a check or a cash. Uh,
thank you so much for spending time
with us. Thank you all for, uh,
hanging out with us here, uh, at the
talks at Google and thanks for the team,
for getting all this done. Uh, ladies
and gentlemen, you mentioned needs.
Okay.